[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants bonsoir les enfants
avez-vous été sage aujourd'hui avez-vous
je te sage aujourd'hui et Nounours
est-il sage nounours
utile sage nounours est sage toujours
sage patron il descend chez ses amis
je vous ai bien attrapé on ne me la fait
pas à moi
on va lui téléphoner oui tu seras plus
facile bonsoir La Maison du alors on
tape à la machine
nous ne connaissons pas son numéro je
vais vous le faire
voyons roux
[Musique]
1 2 3 4 5 et 6 qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire roue roulotte
[Musique]
il répond allô
on entend rien tu es sûr qu'il a le
téléphone évidemment c'est moi qui l'ai
installé
[Musique]
bonjour cornichon
par le plus fort
j'entends très mal
oh tu as des ennuis
une chèvre une chèvre oui elle est venue
manger la voix de Dada
attends nous allons lui chanter une
chanson à ta chèvre d'accord nours oui
la chanson de la chèvre
il te tue une chèvre de forte
température
[Musique]
elle est dans laquelle les grignotant
et poireaux quand fallait bien autant le
Normand le signa devant le par l'homme
le temps de la queue et notre temps
dedans
[Musique]
la chèvre sur Randy et sa Cissé sur un
banc puis the louvrit la porte et
regarda dedans de la queue
[Musique]
elle vit que son affaire allait fort
tristement l'or et l'ouvrit la portée
pris la clé de chant pas le temps de la
queue
dedans pas le temps de la queue et
grignotant
ah bon la chèvre aussi elle est partie
tant mieux ah oui
c'est bientôt
encore mieux
mon bon souvenir à dada
[Musique]
cornichon
tu as entendu bonsoir
et où sont-ils passés
[Musique]
tant mieux les enfants allons j'éteins
la lumière
bonne nuit
bonne nuit nounou à demain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on y va pas trop qu'as-tu nounours tu es
triste je suis fatigué toujours
descendre et remonter cette échelle
oh pauvre nounours quelle dure métier
que le tien
achetez-moi des vitamines patrons j'ai
compris gros coquin tu as envie de miel
allons en route je t'en achèterai un
kilo oh je me sens déjà mieux en route
bonne nuit les petits
faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]